might as well tell you listen I was
telling you guys this the other day
so I got Ulster rate of colitis oh I
have stomach issues man I got [__] I
when I have to go I have to go and then
you don't know when it stops and oh it's
a problem so I asked the UFC to find me
a a stall a little bit um private
because I got stomach issues right so
they brought me next to another one that
wasn't so open and it was through the
spike with the showers and stuff so I'm
in there doing my business
and also and I hear some people by the
[__] showers and it was grown in his
whole crew and it was right after the
loss right oh no so I'm in the they
don't know I'm in there so I'm like oh
no
I'm like I'm clenching my ass and I'm
like and he's awesome I hear uh you know
man you know that fight sucks and he's
like stressing he's inventing to his
team you know nothing crazy but yeah
it's normal after a loss to be yeah and
the team's being quiet all I know is I'm
stuck in the [__] stall I want to
sneak out the door is there I could make
it but they're going to see me
the sink is over there I got to wash my
hands don't you ever think about saying
hey guys it's Matt Sarah I'm taking a
[__] I didn't know what to no I didn't
know what to say because they were
trying to consult like so I ended up
finishing I finished and I walk out I go
over I wash my hands and he looks up and
goes what's up Sarah I'm like hey Chrome
I go and you don't know what to say you
know I and I've been there obviously I
got my losses it's like wait man I go
look man to be honest you're gonna feel
like this until you kick someone else's
ass that's gonna that's gonna help it
yeah man yeah bye
lamb it's hilarious
scenario I want to see that in a cartoon
yeah right
gets me in trouble